Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors again answering your important questions.
How about this question, can you give me medical advice?
Everybody wants to know medical advice sometimes because they're not trusting the advice
that they're getting from their oncologist or their medical doctor and I get that.
It's a big decision making process.
Should you do this therapy or that therapy or this drug or that drug?
These are big tough decisions and you do want to gain as much information from as many
different sources as possible so that you can weigh out your decision and be able to
really understand how to pray about it and how to come about your decision making process.
But the simple answer to this is can we give out medical advice?
The answer is no.
I'm not a licensed medical doctor and I don't pretend to be one and I don't give out medical
advice.
We are try very diligently to stay within our scope of practice.
Our scope of practice and the purpose that God has us here for is to use specific nutrition,
different herbs, different neuters, neutersuticles, make recommendation and diet, support you emotionally
and spiritually and use frequencies, God given frequencies because that's when everything
all better is this energy vibrating in a frequency to use those to help your body heal.
We're not healing directly through those things.
We're not giving you a piece of nutrition that's going to go in there and kill your cancer.
That's not how it works.
Anything we're doing is we're stimulating your body trying to clean up the maloo of where
the cancer is to help with detoxification processes so that your body can heal.
We do not give medical advice.
We cannot tell you what to do or counteract anything that your medical doctor slash oncologist
slash radiologist or surgeon has told you to do.
That is not our position.
Now, we can lead you down different pathways in the way that, hey, look at this information.
Here's some studies, do your own research, do a search on that.
We can encourage that or we're not going to tell you what to do or not to do.
That leads to the next question, will you tell me whether I should do chemo or immunotherapy
or surgery or radiation?
The answer is no, we won't.
We can't, again, that's medical advice.
We can't tell you to do or not to do something.
We can help you walk through that decision as a brother or sister in Christ.
We can help you walk through that decision given maybe a balanced approach to the data
that's out there so that you can know what to, it's going to be the best thing for you,
but understand, we are not dogmatically in position against chemo or radiation or surgery.
I think it has saved many people's lives.
That's, that's be realistic about it.
I think to have a practitioner that's so dogmatically positioned either way is, is, is not just for you.
So there's a time when chemo, radiation, surgery is the right thing to do.
And I can't tell you if that is that for you, you have to make that decision for yourself.
I know we all want to give responsibility to somebody else and I know we're trying to seek
the right thing out for us to do, but all I can do is lead you to help ask different questions,
lead you through some of the data and give you my knowledge about it.
You have to make your decision ultimately.
That is your responsibility.
And lastly, can I get information and advice on my medication?
I'm trying to get off of these steroids or I want to go off of this.
How do I weed off of this?
Don't ask us that.
That's not our place.
That's not where we're to help you with.
You can do whatever you want.
We highly suggest you talk to the prescribing physician in your case if you're wanting to get off something
or to utilize something, but that's outside of our scope.
Our purpose is to be available to you.
We will be available on our Zoom calls.
We're available on a visit by visit basis.
You can call and make an appointment.
We're here to talk.
We're here to throw ideas out to work through some of the thought processes.
We're here to retest.
Understand that once you get tested with us, we may need to retest as your body's chemistry
changes.
We're here to tweak and we're here to pray for you because ultimately, we know that God
has sovereign in all things and we're here to bring Him glory.
So anything that we could do to help you walk through this pathway that you're walking
through, maybe with little support of your family, maybe with great support.
But we can guide you in different ways, but we cannot give you medical advice or make medical
suggestions for you.
That decision does come down to you and that is your responsibility.
So seek the wisdom of a multitude of counselors that would be my advice to you as well.
Know that we'll be praying for you through all things.